(MUFFLED COMMOTION)
If I was gonna look up
one problem cop
as a prime example
of what's gone wrong
here in Baltimore,
where would I start?
WAYNE JENKINS:
I guess we wanna--
Yeah, we wanna run
a little hypothetical by you.
Say we're all
on an investigation,
following a big time
drug dealer,
a real fuckin' monster, right.
We, uh-- Yeah, we get wind
on where he's keeping his cash,
and we actually come upon
that cash.
It's right there in front of us,
and we just...
You know, we take it.
What would you think about that?
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
Everything changed when they
came up with that expression,
"The war on drugs."
With a war,
comes police militarization.
It's a complete gutting
of the Fourth Amendment.
JEMELL RAYAM:
They put me in a unit
made up of a bunch
of the biggest crooks
in the whole goddamn
department.
There's all this money
to be made
and I'm somehow supposed
to be playing by the book
with these motherfuckers?
Jackpot, motherfuckers! Woo!
NICOLE STEELE:
So these cops caught lying,
and with their abusive behavior,
remained on the street?
They did.
RAYAM: If it is the feds
who are on this,
the case could go on
for years.
What case?
This ain't no Pablo Escobar.
This is the police.
BRIAN GRABLER:
In a war, you need warriors.
On the ground!
Get down on the ground!
GRABLER:
You have enemies.
In a war, civilians get hurt
and nobody does anything.
In a war, you count the bodies
and then
you call them victories.
Aren't you angry?
(SCOFFS)
(INHALES, EXHALES)